amazon is taking the plunge diving into
an already crowded streaming market with
a new subscription music service the
Maine unlimited subscription is in line
with Spotify and Apple music at almost
$10 a month but Amazon is sweetening of
the deal for prime customers with a
discounted subscription plan $7.99 a
month and just 399 for users with an
echo Amazon has significantly expanded
its library which previously had just 2
million songs and get this gives a boost
to echo of course just ahead of the
holiday shopping season joining me now
with more are Bloomberg News reporter
Spencer Soper who covers Amazon for us
so Spencer what's your first take on how
compelling the bells and whistles are I
know they say tens of millions of songs
talk to us about the library the
subscription plan and whether or not you
think customers will sign on yeah I
think the big thing is that it's a
message that Amazon is getting more
serious about music they've had a pretty
vanilla catalogue for years now and it's
really just been subpar for a real
serious music enthusiast about 2 million
songs so the fact that they're
increasing the songs catalog so much and
and it will include you know more new
releases from top artists indicates that
they're just getting more more serious
about about the music push and you hit
on the on the key points you know price
price comparable with Spotify but then
sweetener for Prime members and I think
the big takeaway is the the promotion
for the echo how they're kind of looking
to bundle your music streaming with a
purchase of an of an echo
voice-activated speaker right really
sweet deal if you own an echo assuming
that the library is comparable which we
don't know for sure yet Amazon isn't the
only tech Titan that's tried and failed
in the music streaming business I mean
the graveyard is littered with other
efforts here does echo really make this
different how much will you know having
an echo the benefits for echo owners
actually increase the potential success
of this thing well music is a key
gateway for the echo so the echo has
abundant capabilities it's more than a
thousand now it's difficult to even keep
track of all the new functions like you
can dim your lights you can order a
pizza
can do all of these things through voice
command through the echo and but this is
definitely kind of a play heading into
the holiday season they've also
introduced a very low cost echo at $50
which you'd attach to your own speaker
but they definitely want to get this get
people excited about it and so the the
cheaper music streaming option is a way
to get people excited and maybe and
bring it at at a lower at a lower price
point and threat do we think Amazon is -
Spotify you know there was concern that
Apple music would make a big dent in
Spotify users it hasn't thus far so at
this point you know with these this new
plan how much do you think this could
impact Spotify and what about Pandora as
well which is going through a rebrand
and pushing its own coming on-demand
service yeah you have to think of it as
a long-term threat you know you don't
see it as this immediate overnight
everybody drops one thing and switches
to another but Amazon plays this slow
steady game you've seen it with video
where they kind of come in slowly and
gradually increase increase their
offerings and and music is going to be
similar and even with logistics they
keep refining getting better getting
faster so it I think long term it it's
it's a considerable threat and I'm sure
that the the executives where those
companies are definitely watching what
Amazon is doing